hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm finally back home in Cincinnati
where I belong seriously guys
it has been a long arduous journey and
there are so many cool videos for you
guys to see but I am just excited to be
back in my own apartment recording
videos for you guys again I've got so
many great things for you to see in the
next few weeks but no time for that
because apparently while I was gone my
computer was so excited to see me that
it crapped its own pants which is why
I'm late for this video today because I
was up all morning reinstalling all my
software because everything decided to
go to poop so don't worry copy I'm not
gonna tell anyone that you crapped your
pants and excitement in me and I'm
definitely not gonna replace you in the
next few weeks thing okay anyway so
we're back in the game here and we just
uh saw daddy about this lecture hallway
and I don't really know what I'm
supposed to do but apparently is Michael
here Michael Statham the son of Jason
Statham not quite as badass or bald
decided that he was going to go into
Lonnie has a birthday of 619 I don't
know I don't know what I'm supposed to
do but I'm absolutely sure I'm there's a
clue in here somewhere because it's
glowing so today we can must pay tribute
hooked it God you and your English
trying attempts okay anyway so there's a
scholarly book called the regal
collection and there's a professor named
Cindy Peterson global journey
jurisprudence oh wow
very cool class but other than that I
assume squiggly on the blackboard did
the clock there there's a oh my god I
have no okay let's look for Cindy
Peterson's room
I believe that sweet Cindy Peterson's
room was that on the third floor I don't
know I have no idea I really don't know
but I believe I saw ascending Peterson
somewhere
Cindy Pentagon oh boy wait do I need oh
I need open this box I don't know the
count for this box all the numbers that
I wrote down or back in my hotel room
back in Los Angeles so let's use our
giant brain one one one one yard it the
code must be when did I get this code oh
wait the first day that's right okay Oh
619 oh yeah yeah yeah uh okay that's his
birthday duh was him and Michaels her
and Michael Statham were they a little
bit like you know oh sorry you know how
y'all you know you know wrestling okay
anyway I got a key to what kita what did
you say the lecture rooms ah ah now I
can go back and finally open up all of
the lecture rooms okay men I am terribly
stupid but you got to remember I'm still
disoriented from these two labs so smart
you all don't even know how smart I am I
cousin Aaron C note on the board notice
about a seminar
9:21 Oh nine to one okay
crime among the impoverished and his
prevention even a belief serves criminal
behavior a psychological approach will
be referenced so be sure to read it
before coming professor of criminology
Franz more okay so Franz more room and
apparently they want me to read a book
called criminal behavior yeah got from a
notebook I knew there was something I
lacked but I didn't want to admit it my
ambitious usefulness wouldn't let me I
wanted to say it I wanted to be woken up
to be told I'm a half not lacking I have
not
why did the music cut out it's true
there are haves and have-nots people
whose dreams can come true and oh ah
again sometimes my head's start hurting
bad Oh Yugi God fine who wears a cover
up guy oh can I not can you not could
you could you let go please pretty
please
today I'm monster why are you chasing me
ooh oh good
how about no
what
what happened
he just decides to let me go because I
asked him why he's chasing me
he'll kill me every other time and now
he will not favor say okay I thought it
would kill me but he left dammit dammit
who didn't kill me because I'm a
masochistic okay we can pass the kiss my
neck hurts well maybe he was just
stretching you out a little bit well no
no not not not no he was no he wasn't
nevermind he wasn't doing anything never
absolutely never mind
okay I'm going slow now all of a sudden
is that mean there's something important
that I need to do
maybe something here trash cans empty
been fun for me okay so I'm going slow
all of a sudden let me see oh my health
is low I'm at 20 HP level one and only
20 mana so let's see I need to Goose
Fran's Bleeth room Franz is room which
is probably on the third floor why am I
going so slow cuz I'm in Jordan oh so
tired I believe that there was a Fran's
more over here no rate Wayne is his
friends more room wasn't I already up
here though yeah there we go
alright so I'm in France Moore's room
which is the guy that is important and
let's see
no yeah I've already been here before
ah but Andrews rum was mentioned in that
thing he wasn't it it was also something
about a law of criminology I'm confused
wait no if there was wait no if it told
me to read a specific Brooke there was
that big library that was right over
here oh wow what did he break your legs
to do some this thing about not liking
people there was something in these
shelves
international law international law
criminology aha wait did I get this
before the notice in the lecturer
mentioned this I don't understand a word
of it this is LeBeau ah 9 9 8 1 9 9 a 1
there's always money in the nothing okay
computer room locked when did I get it
har ler Oh No
oh maybe I can open the box in France
mordrem unless I already opened that one
I I want to say that I already opened
that one but I'm not entirely sure right
now I've got an entire I just watched
Emperor's New Groove um I got Kronk
voice stuck in my head oh the poison for
kuzco kuzco's poison no I opened it eggs
McGuire's women I need to go back to
kuzco's poison the poison for kuzco
kuzco's poison right order up okay never
mind
they're all okay I'm I'm I'm back at
home with my awesome 350 dollar
microphone again which is totally my
favor ever ever ever ever ever ever and
makes my voice sound like delicious
butter on a moonlit night on Christmas
yeah oh the computer room I can go to
think that I just walked past and lock
uh-huh but so slow oh my neck it hurts
so much you know now that I mentioned
the neck thing The Crooked Man now that
I look at it he looks like a guy after
he got hanged if I'm not mistaken so
there might be something along those
line looking a glowy do daddy oh boy
you know if the crooked man comes and I
have to fight him again this is gonna be
tough lots of complicated patterns I
don't entertain any of em Oh
seventeen there's a six digit code one
for I don't have any pens opit with I
don't have any okay you guys are gonna
have to remember this one four four two
four six one four four two four six one
four four two four six one four four two
four six I'm guessing none of these are
gonna work because they don't have power
okay one four four two four what
happened say what uh hum thank you for
coming today
we're gonna study graduation start of
the reservoir lion the baby lizard
resolve of persistent whole egg is
readily rattled by the laptop but
there's no power maybe this is just
gonna confirm but even if outta this
something I can't help but lament it's
about David Hoover what what it was
highly skilled kind to us all and
admired by his pupils and teachers alike
we all expected he would proudly be
standing with us this morning to
graduate but our hopes were dashed by
none other than the man himself when he
killed himself
what
right let me ask you this should he be
forgiven okay he didn't kill himself can
he escape punishment for betraying his
friends and mentor hmm what what selfish
dreams are you talking about man stop it
stop whoa you the lowest of the low your
dreams will never come true what are you
even good for what I'm so confused right
now go off and die somewhere coward
what okay what the hell Oh
I can't move this is a looping laughing
boom
not laughing at me what is that just
going to get looping as at the end of
the game going on oh hey no I'm not a
cow you know you can move almost as fast
as a Crooked Man when you want to okay
I just hi
I heard a scream was that yo geez you
made me free up g2 made me freak breath
what's the big idea huh
did something happen good god what was
that forget about it
sorry for the surprise it's nothing hey
dude Meister you okay man you're super
pale I'm just kind of tired I came a
long way and I haven't slept leave me
alone I can't be bothered to talk have
this what what huh I already had a
little but it's an energy drink drink up
how is that gonna help me in my
compromised mental state I don't need
this I told you to leave me be Rickard
geez bro what are you some kind of pansy
you really need like you need food and
drink I'm being nice to accept my
kindness ah
alright thanks but what's all this from
who's who's calling from the guy who's
called me a shady Punk mostly because
you look like crap dude come on it's not
like I'm a heartless monster I mean I am
trying to be a lawyer besides maybe it's
fake tell you what I won't call your
shady anymore now cheer up you could be
my client which I'm a lawyer ha that's a
quick turnaround I'm grateful at any
rate say have you seen anyone else
around particularly a man my age a man
nope nobody
he's who you're looking for yeah though
I don't really know how he looks tell me
if you see him okay you got it doubt
anybody be around here though can I ask
you something
Professor Andrew he always helped me out
his rooms on the third floor but it's
got a code so I can't get in I was
thinking the professor might still have
some lecture notes for me around or
something but yeah tell me if you can
get it open okay all right got it
I'll wander around some more then
you look like hell so don't push
yourself yeah would you be careful too
if you see any monsters get away not
this again
yeah yes sure I got a knife to defend
myself anyhow smell yeah or smell yeah
man that's gonna be the market Belarus
whoo yeah okay he's not as bad as I
thought got an N oh oh I got an energy
drink
let me just chug a lug that down yeah oh
look at that it healed me up it healed
me up up up all right okay so let's just
carry on I believe one four four two
four six was the note C one four four
four to six that flashed by but my
instantaneous memory will get it one
four four four two six one four four
four two six one four four four two six
or the other way around I don't know
which one but I can now go over here and
open up this door and goddamn I move so
slow what for for four do stick I bet
he's gonna work why four four two four
six four damn Adams demonic ganya Oh
unless I got it totally wrong Oh No haha
I got and isn't the room to the left the
one where I locked the crooked man in
there wasn't he probably kind of come
barging through the door
and got us stab me in the butt crooked
man cereal but steady finally done with
finals I'm glad everyone got their
appropriate grades of course there's
that lone D I teach him so much but he
doesn't even get the basics he's lagging
behind everyone else and he still intend
on being a lawyer that nickname d stands
for dreamer apparently I was giving him
for having such an impossible dream but
if you had me it's really great he
always gets look buddy I hate how he
fawns over me too
I practically I have to act nice to him
and he always come for lessons after
school I wish I'd never let him in my
plan I just hope he finds hope he's
given up on his dream to find another
path this is about D it's awful that
he'd say this about a student though
maybe D really is that bad
if these all this could be a big shock
for him he said he always respected his
professor and always tried so hard there
I tore the page out with one D coming in
and finding this and then
and then I thought for sure the crooked
man would come barreling out what go how
does that help me
hey buddy
that monsters still wandering around is
he looking for me since he couldn't kill
me
I'm gonna have to persuade D to leave
it's way too dangerous for here I'll go
look for him where where do I do that
where do I go and do that two hours late
ow d wait a minute this wasn't a locked
I have a really bad feeling the air
feels kind of heavy just what is this go
down Oh dun da da da da da da da da da
da da boom Balai done hey Dee what's
wrong get up are you dead
can I have your stuff man feels like
crap now that you mention it it's a
little hard to breathe what's going on
here it's gas huh what what are you
doing the floors leaking gas you got to
get out man dee get up lean on my
shoulder okay alright not going out that
way it's that was creepy crap the gas is
pouring in I'll be poisoned if I'm not
quick when we got here I've only got two
minutes what did I get what did I get
iron pipe
wait no wait what what huh
oh wait no it was the thing that said
those and crack of the wall wait no hang
on
wait let me there was a crack in the
wall somewhere it was a crack in the
wall I know this it said there was a
little window there was a crack in the
wall I remember something a long time
ago set those ha yeah so Terrence the
freak down gotta get out come on Maggie
Oh baby no good on maybe if I hit it
more well hit it more hit it more dad I
got a bar
maybe if I hit it more so head on bar
I've got a hammer don't I what if I do
that what's in that box
yeah this is gonna be fruitless I made
it I made it
how did I made it huh huh huh leave the
room oh ah god damn you
you
okay all right I'll do this again next
time all right anyway I'm all out of
time whip with butter
that was stupid dollars you son of a
[ __ ] move right there that was a
bitchiest son of a [ __ ] rum move I've
ever seen in my entire life
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for what
it is that I've done as always I will
see you in the next bye bye
ah